you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
u.s climate envoy john kerry will travel
to china for talks this week
telling sky news all countries need to
step up
should the rich pay more for their
carbon intensive behaviors
a new report suggests the so-called
polluter elite
should foot the bill for activities that
are bad for the climate
and the machines turning used face masks
and hospital gowns into
car bumpers and clothespegs
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening
to our world right now and meet those
coming up with the solutions
this show aims to take you to the heart
of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
u.s climate envoy john kerry will travel
to china this week for crucial talks
ahead of a virtual summit
hosted by joe biden china is the world's
biggest polluter but has yet to say
if it will attend the earth day event
next thursday
but speaking to skies sophie ridge mr
kerry said the climate crisis
is an unbelievable monument to the need
for multilateralism
and called on all countries to step up
the us is responsible for up to 15
percent of emissions
china is responsible for 30 you know
some of our viewers might be thinking
is it really going to make a difference
if people in the uk eat less meat or
cycle more when you consider these
colossal emissions
coming out of the us and china of course
it makes a difference
because every country has to join this
effort as i said a moment ago
no one country no one entity like the eu
can solve the problem this is this is a
unbelievable monument
the climate crisis to the need for
multilateralism
we have been in touch with china i've
talked to my counterpart
a number of times we
recognize that china nearly 30 percent
of the world's emissions
is essential to resolving this crisis
and our hopes are that china is prepared
to
assume responsibility as we are and as
other nations are
this is not a moment where
any nation can not
step up to raise the ambition that paris
envisioned
and and what we're doing now is not
something that we've instigated
particularly
it's the automatic follow-on to the
paris agreement
our climate change correspondent lisa
holland joins me now so lisa john kerry
is going to china so just how
significant
is that anna it's hugely significant
because
the world's worst polluters the united
states and
china quite simply have to come together
on this
issue it says a great deal that john
kerry is the first
and highest profile official from the
biden administration to be
dispatched to china to hold these kinds
of talks
it says a lot about how important
climate change is to the new
u.s administration now we think that he
will go there in the course of the next
week or so
to discuss china's uh global ambitions
when it comes to the climate remember
that
uh china has said that it plans to go
carbon neutral by 2060
but there's still a huge amount of
questions about how china
plans to do that and exactly where it
plans to reduce those emissions and make
those cuts questions too
over exactly what america plans to do to
uh do its bit in helping to reduce
global emissions
um however that does not necessarily
mean that there will be
a meeting of minds john kerry himself
has said he is
hopeful but not confident that he can
count on
china's cooperation however where there
is a will there is a way and it's a
really good sign
that john kerry is officially on his way
to china
lisa thank you and you can see the full
interview with u.s climate envoy john
kerry
on sophie ridge on sunday this weekend
now the world's wealthiest people should
radically change their lifestyles or be
the focus of government policies to
tackle climate change
the cambridge sustainability commission
says it's time for
fairer economies where the richest
reduce their emissions
and the poorest are allowed to develop
well nearly half the growth in absolute
global emissions from 1990
to 2015 was down to the richest 10
percent of people on earth
and more than a third of emissions or 37
percent
came from the wealthiest 5 the so-called
polluter elite
and to make the most impact the richest
of the global population need to reduce
their emissions by a factor
of at least 30 by 2030 and that means
there's more importance given to
policies that can scale up
to tackle the largest polluters such as
taxes on frequent and
further flyers bans on selling and
promoting high polluting vehicles like
suvs
and reinstating the green homes grant
and electric car subsidies
to make climate-friendly options more
affordable
well the report's lead author professor
peter newell says governments need to
make it easier for people
to reduce their carbon footprint a lot
of us don't have direct control really
over how we heat our homes or even the
options available to us to get to work
so we need those options to be
affordable and sustainable and it's the
job of government and business of course
and cities
to do the right thing well our chief
political correspondent john craig is in
westminster for us so john how
will the government respond to this do
you think the government will argue that
it is already taking major measures
to reduce carbon emissions for example
as recently as last november boris
johnson announced
a ban on the sale of new petrol and
diesel cars
from 2030. now that's been brought
forward
to 2040 the government will argue that
is a much better record than other
european countries
take spain for example it's 2040. there
are moves to agree a common target
throughout the eu but of course the uk
is not
part of that anymore some of these
measures
the government will argue our
anti-business it wants to show that the
uk
is open for business so for example
frequent flyer levies
are not likely to be adopted by the
government at a time when the aviation
industry is on its knees
thanks to covid bans on promoting
and selling suvs and other high
polluting vehicles
well the motor industry is a very
powerful lobby
the government be reluctant to do
anything that threatens jobs there
interesting there's nothing on the on
the fuel duty in this report
and what is more likely though is
perhaps
grants for electric cars and green homes
and so on
so some of these measures will get the
go ahead
but probably not that many john craig
thank you
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and
citron has said it will offer an
electrified option on all of its
vehicles by
2025. chief executive vincent kobay
told sky news the demand for electric
cars has accelerated in the last year
the governments have been providing
subsidies not only to purchase but to
the development
of infrastructure the car makers have
stepped up to the plate by accelerating
the development and introduction of
electrified technology
and i think the consumers have also made
a substantial move you see this in the
numbers
new zealand has become the first country
to introduce a climate law for
financial firms under the new
legislation banks and insurers with
assets of more than one billion
new zealand dollars will have to explain
how they manage
climate-related risks around 200 of the
country's biggest companies
will have to provide their first report
in 2023.
the united states is being urged to cut
at least 50 percent of its greenhouse
gas emissions by 2030.
107 european politicians companies and
trade unions
have released a joint statement calling
on the u.s to take
greater action president biden's
administration is expected to announce a
new
national emissions target at a virtual
summit with world leaders next week
microplastic particles and fibers are
now so common
that they're being carried around the
world in the air we breathe
scientists from utah state and cornell
universities found
plastic is spiraling around the globe in
a cycle
similar to natural processes like the
carbon cycle
various studies suggest breathing in
microplastics can damage
lungs and poison kidneys
and nature charity plant life is urging
people to take part in a cow slip survey
to help monitor how healthy the uk's
wildflower meadows are
it's part of a european study which
looks at the centre of the flower
and records which type of cow slip it is
the charity says in a healthy field
there should be a 50 50 ratio of the two
types
more than a million tons of radioactive
water from the destroyed fukushima
nuclear plant in japan
is going to be released into the pacific
ocean the decision has been widely
criticized by
neighbouring countries as well as local
fishermen and residents
here's why the decision is so
controversial
[Music]
slag
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
alright
now can you guess what these plastic
blocks used to be
well they're made in less than an hour
and could be turned into anything from
school chairs
to tool boxes and they're made out of
used
ppe specialist thermal heating machines
which convert
waste such as gowns curtains and
single-use masks
into reusable plastic blocks have been
installed in five nhs hospitals
dan whitehead has been seeing how it all
works
[Applause]
the pandemic and plastic have gone hand
in hand
millions of single-use face masks gowns
and curtains have been
vital to the fight against kovid but
it's created
thousands of tons of waste now
six nhs hospitals have installed
specialist machines
that convert used ppe into reusable
plastic
we have a number of trusts now using our
machines
and specifically to
take out the plastics and also the face
mask which has become a huge problem in
the current pandemic
you take royal cornwall for instance
they're using 10 000 masks a day
we've got around 3 000 faulty single-use
face masks here what happens is they go
inside the machine
at the hospital for around an hour what
comes out is this 20
kilogram block of plastic it's being
reused already to make things like
toolboxes
and new school chairs one survey
suggests
19.2 billion single-use face masks were
used in the uk in the last
year that's about the equivalent weight
of 37
000 cars a huge amount but still a tiny
proportion
of the 220 million tons of waste the uk
produces
every year the waste management system
has coped
it's very resilient system we are not
talking about huge amount of volumes of
material compared to the overall amount
that we're handling
for the uk as a whole in any given year
there is little sign of ppe demand
falling
being able to turn this covered waste
into something new
could be a long-term solution dan
whitehead sky news
in cardiff coming up on the daily
climate show tomorrow we've got an
exclusive interview with cristiano
figueres the woman who made history
negotiating the landmark paris 2015
agreement on climate change getting
nearly 200 countries
to sign up you can see that tomorrow on
sky news on
our social channels website and app see
you then